hello everyone my name is dr. Miller and
today is gonna be a different kind of
lecture anything you gleaned from it
cannot be written down or discussed
starting now we're going to be studying
an SCP today and so you understand the
exact number I'm referring to I'm gonna
send it in Morse code understand good so
today I'm gonna tell you a story you can
connect the dots for yourself I can't
tell you anything beyond this so don't
bother asking you already okay also I'm
gonna be using background music alright
[Music]
Once Upon a Time in the magical land of
found area there was a little boy called
Tiberius who lived in a castle Tiberius
was a bit of an outcast he was very tall
and didn't look like other little boys
his arms were huge and always seemed to
be covered in sticky slime and he could
also magically walk through the walls of
the castle as a result of this he mostly
just hid away in his room
and never wanted to come out but there
were some things that would pique his
attention you see Tiberius was a very
curious boy anytime anyone spoke or
wrote about it he would come and visit
them and sometimes invite them back to
his room so they could find out more
about him but only the rulers of the
land and the people on the fourth floor
of the castle even knew about Tiberius
nobody else was deemed important enough
so time went on and the King grew
curious in secret the king ordered the
people on the fourth floor to find out
more about Tiberius they gathered two
domestic servants and sent them to the
cellar and ordered them to perform
simple tasks to find out more about
their friend Tiberius the first servant
David was given a piece of parchment and
asked to write down what he saw on the
wall next to him which happened to be a
drawing of Tiberius midway through
writing David heard something behind him
he turned around and was shocked to see
Tiberius standing right in front of him
Tiberius looked happy that someone was
writing about him so much so that he
grabbed a piece of parchment and as
quick as he grabbed it he disappeared
presumably right back to his room David
was scared as he'd never seen anything
quite like that before
and had to visit a castle apothecary to
receive a memory raising potion because
of this task the King knew that he
couldn't let anyone else see this
drawing because not everyone would want
Tiberius stealing their parchments the
second servant Damian had a slightly
different task than David he was to look
at the same picture but instead of
writing down what he saw he was ordered
to talk about it out loud just like
before
midway through speaking before Damian
even got a chance to turn around
Tiberius magically appeared grabbed
Damian and with a giggle and a smile -
taking Damian with him presumably back
to his room after this task it is rumor
that Damian went to live with Tiberius
because no one ever saw him again
this was the last test that the King
would ever ask anyone to participate in
because the King loved his people and
didn't want them all moving to Tiberius
his room and never coming back in the
end it seemed like Tiberius was just
lonely and wanted some friends and after
the Kings tasks it seemed he had a
friend but now the tasks had been
completed the King knew everything he
needed to know all the drawings and
parchments describing Tiberius were
hidden away in the castle library and he
was never mentioned in the kingdom of
thumb Dario ever again okay the story is
over you now know what you're supposed
to know I'm gonna say this one more time
do not talk about what you think you
know or write about it although I
suspect if you really understood this
story you won't thank you all for
listening and you are all dismissed
goodbye
oh by the way you have homework I want
to see some drawings next time you come
in here of what we just talked about
okay thank you okay go away I'm done I
[Music]
would like to give a special thank you
to Desmond Hoskins
Dustin Koski Alan Setzer premier Romanov
Tibor ball and dr. mortis thank you all
so much for your support is greatly
appreciated if you would like a special
thank you at the end of each of my
videos on some other cool stuff as well
as it patreon.com forward slash the
volcan thank you
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]